I was astonished how few black officers
there are and now you are that role
model
the first African-American Chief of
Staff of any of the forces I mean you've
been nominated to for chairman to be the
second after Colin Powell but is that
part of what goes through your mind
there's a there's a whole uh group of
people who are paying particular
attention to you to learn from you to
follow you you are a role model you know
I would say yes and no I mean I I think
about it but I don't know
because as I came into the air force I
want to be the the best officer the best
F-16 pod the best commander not the best
black polisher best black F-16 best
black Commander it's the aspect of you
can be anything you want to be and
um as long as you put your mind to it
and one of the things I think is
important for me in this position
is I believe uh people only aspire to be
what they see you never you know grow
decide you want to grow it to be
something you've never seen
and ideally about me being in this
position uh I you know show that um yeah
you can do this whether you look like me
or not you want to make sure that uh I'm
not the last I want to make sure the
door opens up for others not just at
this level you know not everybody gets
to be the chief of staff there for sure
or be nominated to be the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs but it's the Opera
opening the door so that everyone
who joins our military can reach their
full potential uh and that's I mean
that's what my focus is by you know
being in this position because I think
that's important